hello freak [ __ ] I would love to play
you the dinosaurs are not real video
just do it God
we probably can't play it on YouTube
where we'll get pulled but we could play
the audio right play the I will put the
video up on the screen and play the
audio for you and you could just [ __ ] it
your head could turn beet red smokes
could come out of your ears because the
thing is about these videos and this is
the issue that I have with not just
videos but also with blogs people you're
writing things and you're not you're not
being checked as you're going along so
it's it's just you broadcasting an idea
it's not a conversation and because of
that you can give off the illusion of
expertise without being checked here it
goes dinosaurs never existed and by the
my god Eric Dubay this is the flat yeah
the guy that does 200 proofs the earth
is flat everybody has debunked [ __ ]
no no no she kills she'll yes yes shows
are listen to this guy don't you dare
mention Owens name the brass holes in
1842 or in other words the existence of
dinosaurs was first speculatively
hypothesized by United Museum head
coincidentally in the mid 19th century
during the heyday of evolutionism before
a single dinosaur fossil had ever been
found
wrong they pause every time pause
dinosaurs we we discovered marine
reptiles and the first dinosaurs about a
century before that so that right there
Eric you're [ __ ] wrong whoops it's
like don't bring your Flat Earth
[ __ ] into my profession now I'm
pissed
well we keep going yeah keep keep us
rolling constrain press worldwide got to
work
hyping stories of these supposedly long
lost animals and then lo and behold 12
years later in 1854 Ferdinand van Devere
Haydn during his exploration of the
upper Missouri River
proof of Owens theory a few unidentified
teeth he mailed two leading
paleontologist Joseph Lee D mm-hmm who
several years later declared them to be
from an ancient extinct tract Adhan
dinosaur which beyond ironic so that's
because we can do things like look at
modern analogues and see how teeth are
[ __ ] made we know if it's a predator
or if its prey we know if it's an
herbivore or a carnivore we know how to
thar [ __ ] built even back then even
when they're doing naturalistic drawings
like this it's like like the the
Megalodon tooth on my arm
it is a predator it's obviously a
serrated Megalodon or Megalodon how do
you say it it's it depends can be on a
different sulabha it's it's both it's
not like nuclear and nucular
no no because because it doesn't have to
use but it's spelled it's spelled the
same but it's like Dimetrodon or
Dimetrodon is it the same thing Magali
Donn or Megalodon yeah keep doing it
what is it 20 minutes firstly it should
be needless to say that it is impossible
to reconstruct an entire hypothetical
ancient animal based on a few teeth but
even more importantly it is dubious that
a myriad of Baguio tile bird and reptile
mammal transitional forms necessary for
the blossoming theory of evolution would
be hypothesized and then conveniently
discovered by teams of evolutionist
archaeologists purposely out looking to
find such fossils and Glenna Brundtland
is even more dubious that such fossils
have supposedly existed for millions of
years but were never found by or known
to any civilization in the history of
humanity okay evolution
okay yeah the reason why we didn't know
about things beforehand because we
weren't doing [ __ ] like wholesale
intellectual studies of science when
people were building [ __ ] pyramids
and stuff like that that's why we have
different ages in throughout
anthropological records we have the
broad age and iron
and all that because we have to do
things like figure out the land around
us and when we start finding really old
bones like hey this looks like a really
big chicken bone what the [ __ ]
or this looks like a huge human with a
single eye what the [ __ ] we start
looking at stuff like that saying just
wholesale [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
goddamn but that's a that's what a
YouTube videos YouTube conspiracy theory
video is oh it's not one person getting
to spill there's nonsense and they're
unchecked yes why was this for you and
response videos can be blocked by the
original person they can curate all
comments they can only allow certain
ones through they can moderate
everything same with a blog same with
all that they control their own
criticism mm-hmm there's a guy right now
that a lot of the paleo communities
going after his name's David Peters he's
a jackass who's like doing stupid things
like all reptiles are mammals and all of
these clades should be in this and just
all this crap
he wholesale copied an article from a
colleague of mine posted it which is a
violation of copyright because he's
attempting to supersede that work by
importing his own ideas to it he will
refuse any critical comments to be
posted on his WordPress site hmm that's
really common though yeah it's really
common with people the war of ideas in
the comment section that's where it's
being fought yeah it's because it's an
echo chamber yeah it's like people don't
look as why do people think the world is
flat or why do people think dinosaurs
don't exist they're Google boolean
search is dinosaurs don't exist or
creationism is true evolution is false
the earth is flat chemtrails exist
they're creating their own echo chamber
and preaching to their own [ __ ] choir
yeah and then they have a message board
and then go on that message board
massive confirmation bias nobody anybody
that doesn't follow that line gets
booted out let's play more of this
because this gets better soon isms
Masonic Renaissance it
mid 19th century David Wozniak ins in
all the years previous when they roamed
the American continents because they
weren't doing a [ __ ] dinosaurs in the
Native American religion or tradition
because they were all dead that matter
why were there no discoveries prior to
the 19th century in any part of the
world there could have gone you didn't
know what it was that's the world book
and it's like the same thing with
mammoths Cyclops we didn't know what the
[ __ ] it was we didn't know as a massive
you know a massive elephant species we
thought was a giant person yeah when the
first animals were discovered in the
liberated Tar Pits before 1913 they
thought it was livestock that got
trapped in there and died
then they realized holy [ __ ] cows don't
have 9 inch long incisors that are you
know perfectly evolved you slash open
the throats of things and then you
started questioning
so the Native Americans and all the
people they were finding possibly
scatters of bone and didn't know what it
was did the did the northern first
people start licking bones and rocks no
we we discovered that you know the
science as it figures out going hey this
is porous material if I lick porous
material it's gonna stick to my tongue
holy [ __ ] that's a fossil this this kind
of just he the problem with you Eric is
you are starting from an improper
position you are starting on a
confirmation bias you are stating from
the beginning that dinosaurs don't exist
and you were using parody Leah and
apophenia the ability for humans to find
patterns in order to fit your [ __ ]
and then only cherry-pick what belongs
that's that's what that's what he does
with [ __ ] Flat Earth and the problem
with this is like I was saying earlier
because now the stupid minority has a
voice all I don't know how many million
people subscribe to his [ __ ] channel
every single Flat Earth [ __ ] is gonna
go sixty one thousand people okay look
at that 300,000
use and here's the thing check out the
comments that comments he curates icons
down are almost identical look 3486 the
3494 are you kidding me but remember
being forced to have the same dinosaur
toys as everyone Matt yeah that's
because it's called consumerism flatter
if no dinosaur what's the point in
making these ok see good good for you go
in there extremely great research love
is very amazing Thank You Max Haskins
don't breed don't ruin dinosaurs with
facts [ __ ] you were my favorite animal
here's another problem
his voice is annoying it's [ __ ] oh my
god let's play more oh thanks I mean
open sale appeared before the 1800s no
one ever knew that dinosaurs existed
during the late 1800s and early 1900s
large deposits of dinosaur remains were
discovered why his man suddenly made all
these discoveries no tribes cultures or
countries in the world ever discovered a
dinosaur bone before the mid-1800s and
then they were suddenly found all over
the world in North America South America
Europe Asia Africa Argentina Belgium
Mongolia Tanzania West Germany and many
other places apparently had larger
deposits of dinosaur fossils never
before seen that's because we find the
first one and then were like holy [ __ ]
there must be more of these out there
and then the bone war started between
Ogden and Marsh you had the mantle
collection with the first Iguanodon that
was found and they put it and they made
these really stupid statues and put him
in Crystal Palace in London and Mary
Anning one of the first female the first
female paleontologist and one of the
first people actually find fossils she
discovered the ichthyosaur Mary Anning
was the girl from the rhyme she sells
seashells on the seashore because that's
what she did as a child and as she was
looking for seashells she found a
skeleton of an ichthyosaur
buried in a cliff oh yeah as like a kid
I think she was 12 13
I think paleontology Twitter is gonna
rip me apart from not knowing the thing
but come on I'm hyped up now drunk he's
hyped up I'm not dude that's one beer
all right I've got ya before you got
here none excited I've got nine more in
there I'm gonna need them
yeah it's just so Mary Anning discovered
it via Soares and once you discover
something like that you want to go
around the world and say hey where else
is this stuff let's go somewhere that no
one has been hmm
which means North America South America
Tanzania Belize all the things that
captain jackass just rattled off Captain
[ __ ] let's bomb cap cap nut face
[ __ ] [ __ ] wooded [ __ ] Gibbon I don't
know just something oh yeah I stole that
I stole [ __ ] given from a trauma thing
but it give it [ __ ] given one that we
like a monkey like a Gibbon ma a I think
they're technically Apes
I think Gibbons rapes have tails
no all right please all apes monkeys but
not all monkeys or Apes no apes and
monkeys are prying but a monkey is just
it's not a technical term right it's not
a scientific term there was an article
that was written there's explaining that
all Apes are monkeys but not all monkeys
or Apes see if you can find that well
let's we'll go to that afterwards you
know that probably because one of those
beers all right let's let's keep this
rolling well I don't want to I want to
see how deep we can go with this for
this time why had no one ever found a
dinosaur fossil before according to the
book the dinosaur project
paleontological journalist Wayne Grady
things the period following this from
around 1870 to 1880 became a period in
North America where some of the most
underhanded shenanigans in the history
of science were conducted that's because
the paleontologists going at it against
each other going I can find the cooler
thing no I can find the cooler thing I'm
gonna find more [ __ ] than you it was
called the bone Wars Ogden vs. Marsh he
already talked about this right yeah
what it was was underhanded about it
they would they would sabotage each
other's digs
they would try and yeah steal fossils
they were [ __ ] but because of the
competition it's it's like a fight when
you have one dude that you know two
dudes have been training all their lives
and try and do the whole thing the more
amped up one gets the more amped up the
others get it's gonna be a [ __ ] just
Throwdown this is what happened on an
intellectual and fieldwork scale you had
two guys trying to make a name for
themselves in a burgeoning brand new
field that just wanted to get in and
roll and they had direct competition
with each other so it's gonna be you
know [ __ ] you I'm gonna find these bones
first and it got nasty man Wow
yeah it's like it's think of it as
Edison versus Tesla paleontology right
except a Tesla wasn't very aggressive
he's sort of like let all that [ __ ] yeah
true true very true play it people keep
this going
Owen as the great dinosaur Rush born the
bone Wars Edward drinker cope of the
Academy of Sciences Marsh Rafael Marsh
of the peabody museum of natural history
began a lifelong rivalry and passion for
dinosaur huh yeah I said or done it oh
my bad but became bitter enemies during
a legendary feud involving
double-crossing slander bribery theft
spying and destruction of bones by both
parties Marsh is said to have discovered
over 500 different ancient species
including 80 dinosaurs while cope
discovered 56 out of the hundred and
thirty-six dinosaur species supposedly
discovered by the two men however you
for sanction pose 32 are presently
considered valid as the rest have all
proven to be falsifications and
fabrications [ __ ] bull [ __ ] not a
falsification or fabrication turns out a
lot of those dinosaurs were the same
species that were previously discovered
so oh look this sauropod femur looks a
lot like that sauropod femur but I found
this slightly in a different place so
I'm going to name it a new species
nup turns out those are both
brontosaurus or Apatosaurus or
Triceratops or stegosaurs anything like
that that that that is just an outright
[ __ ]
that he just said when things are
discovered and it turns out that they're
the same
it becomes taxonomically what's called a
junior synonym so for example
Tyrannosaurus Rex had another name for a
really long time it's totally syn mega
mega lot know what regardless whatever
the first name for it was was
technically the first discovered name
for it but since Teran asaurus rex
became the more popular the more
documented the more thing that became a
junior synonym or what or and obscured
that one actually became what we call no
mum obscure him there were the obscure
name no longer no longer talked about
but that's what happened it wasn't an
outright fabrication it was two dudes
finding bones of the same species or
type of animal but not naming it the
same thing so that's that's an absolute
[ __ ] Eric Dubay outright lie lifts
them once claimed to find a complete
skeleton either so all their work
involved reconstructions in fact to this
day no complete skeleton has ever been
found bullsháá and so all dinosaurs are
reconstruction [ __ ]
sooo in the Field Museum isn't well not
a hundred percent complete ninety-eight
percent complete including formerly
unknown elements from any other Taranis
or I believe a commercial paleontology
group just found like a 99% or almost a
100 percent complete dinosaur we have
found entireties or near entireties of
animals so he's right by a very small
technicality of one or two percent
exactly exactly but what he's implying
is completely misleading
yeah he's implying that they're finding
a shin bone and drawing a dinosaur
around exactly but no like we will find
we could find 70 percent of
Tyrannosaurus Rex we know what they look
like so yeah we will use 3d printing or
casting of all that many and yeah I'm
happily admitting this because everyone
knows or at least everyone should know
many dinosaurs in museums are what we
call
it will be a a triceratops the skull
will be real maybe the front half of the
animal some ribs maybe some tail
vertebra or the pelvis will be from one
animal we will have to use casts of
other Triceratops that we have
throughout paleontology in other museums
many of the fossils you see on display
are casts now cast doesn't mean [ __ ]
created on the spot it means very
technically this is a cast it is a
replica of an actual existing bone that
was wrapped made a mold of and then
filled with resin painted to the correct
color it is the exact match of a bone
that exists it is not something we are
just making up that is [ __ ] and I
hate that when they come in and go oh
wow look that's like plastic
yeah it's plants think it's all well
yeah you know why fossils are [ __ ]
fragile it takes us weeks to get a
single bone out and then it is covered
in glue it is wrapped in tissue paper
sometimes tin foil a [ __ ] ton of plaster
and reinforcement is wrapped around it
then it has to be very carefully slid
down a mountain on a car hood in one
time or airlifted out in another and put
in this back of trucks and then taken
all the way to its museum and and
cracked open and then then prepared
everything has to get get left off it
very carefully and we're adding more
glue as we're going because if you
sneeze wrong on some on some mineralized
specimens it goes away it just goes boom
so you have to work very carefully in a
booth with like an Arab Raider so you're
just you're shooting extremely fine
particles just to get the top millimeter
of material off this is hard detailed
work on things that are 65 plus million
years old that if we're not careful they
fall apart we are not going to wrap
something like that in [ __ ] steel and
put it up on a mount especially
somewhere I don't know like Los Angeles
where things like earthquakes happen
it's a statements like that that he may
they're just [ __ ] irritating keep it
keep David Wozniak of arees and
excavations seem not to be made by
disinterested people such as farmers
ranchers hikers or recreationist
[ __ ] building construction [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] lutely [ __ ] [ __ ] you
Eric
I'm a paleo monitor you [ __ ] I am
actually contracted to go out to [ __ ]
building sites and make sure fossils are
protected and dug up correctly in fact
you know what jackass I found a whale in
downtown LA [ __ ] you Eric Dubay you
found a whale
I found a whale in downtown LA oh you
talked about this last podcast you were
talking about how they had a shut down
construction exactly you know why
because building construction finds
[ __ ] dinosaurs and met and whales and
prehistoric animals you jackass oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you farmers so sue was found on a
guy's farm there have been numerous
dinosaurs numerous prehistoric animals
found on a guy's farm by the way there's
an entire private area up in Bakersfield
called shark's tooth hill where they
find Megg teeth mcgowan on tea all the
[ __ ] time and it's angers fields in
Bakersfield it's on private land farmers
builders recreational people yeah hey
guess what a couple people hiking in Red
Rock Canyon up near Palmdale found a
trackway from an ancient camel wreck we
recreational people yeah this happens
all the [ __ ] time the reason why it's
happening more and more lately it's
because people know what they're looking
for now they understand Wow there could
be [ __ ] out here hey if we're digging a
road if we're widening the 99 freeway in
Fresno holy [ __ ] we hit a mammoth or
holy [ __ ] we found a whale in downtown
LA like with within blocks of the 110
freeway and Good Samaritan Hospital I
won't tell you where I can't but yeah
just want to say creepy yeah it's just
part of the part of the contracts that's
that's the deal because if you find
something if you find something there
you can find more [ __ ] mm-hmm we found
over 400 specimens of shark teeth whales
or ribcage of a whale
snails fossil Coral all of this because
town la was underwater seven million
years ago and yeah that's oh my god it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
keep you like blind trench diggers luck
you and mining industry personnel found
all the time by people with a vested
interest such as paleontologists both
scientists university professors and
museum organization personnel who we
need trained [ __ ] dinosaur
bones or who have studied dinosaurs
previously finds are often made during
special dinosaur bone hunting trips and
expeditions by these people to faraway
regions already inhabited and explored
this seems highly implausible more
believable is the case of the discovery
of the first original Dead Sea Scrolls
in 1947 which were unintentionally
discovered by a child and which were all
published by 1955 oh ok so it's
perfectly fine to accidentally find
ancient scrolls or silver denarii I from
the Roman period or a never before known
pyramid in South America oh no that's
cool you know why because humans [ __ ]
made those but it's completely out of
the norm for some kid some nine-year-old
kid to be walking around Montana and
find a mummified hadrosaur because I
don't know why I made that distinction
that's a weird comparison this yeah it's
more plausible to find the Dead Sea
Scrolls in Qumran than it is to find a
Megalodon tooth bull shakers field yeah
no no it doesn't make any sense he's
he's anthropomorphic sizing this and
he's using a very an absolutely invalid
lot invalid argument and logical
fallacies trying he's trying to its
absolute false equivocation he's trying
to go oh well you know you can't find
this stuff because it's super super old
but you can find this stuff because it's
younger and it's humans and you know
people live there so we'd expect stuff
there well guess what [ __ ] there's 65
million years of difference between
humans deciding to write [ __ ] down and
go hey there's a day and a night that
means something's ruling the day in the
night gods religion and Industry and all
that and
dinosaurs eating [ __ ] 65 million years
you we were tree shrews and moles we
didn't we weren't building [ __ ] we
weren't writing stuff down such a false
[ __ ] argument god this guy's a
jackass some cases of a discovery of
dinosaur bones by a disinterested person
it was suggested to them by some
professional in the field no loss
mistake in a certain area
it wasn't also very interesting to note
or special areas set aside and
designated as dinosaur parks because we
found a bunch of [ __ ] bearers are
required to first obtain a dinosaur
hunting license whatever destination
these establishment finest origin is
hard daily intelligence said it seemed
they found incredible numbers of fossils
and tiny areas in one of the largest
dinosaur excavation sites called the
Ruth Mason quarry over 2,000 fossils
were allegedly discovered stop sinks
alleged militant son of a build from
these bones are currently on display in
over 60 museums worldwide yeah because
it's a fantastic site no head of
paleontology at La Plata Museum is
amazingly responsible for 6,000 fossil
species supposedly discovered throughout
his career all in Argentina oh oh really
really hey guess what Eric I ran a lab
that we had three and a half million
specimens from the Ice Age that goes
back ninety thousand years so the La
Brea Tar Pits the largest Ice Age mammal
collection on the [ __ ] planet and
this stuff isn't mineralized it's
actually subsumed with asphalt keeping
the all of the calcium and everything
intact these are actual bones when we
find a saber-toothed cat tooth it's the
physical tooth of the animal ooh which
is kind of freaky to think about but but
but saying that it's like yeah we find a
lot of [ __ ] in places the river of death
in Alberta when they're digging the
pipeline I don't know Mammoth Hot
Springs there are things called death
traps and predator traps and sinkholes
and natural trap
Cades and I don't know entire sand dunes
falling on things while they're fighting
the dueling dinosaurs it's a
Protoceratops versus a velociraptor that
was found in Mongolia because a [ __ ]
sand dune fell on them while they were
tussling around because the V Raptor
wanted to eat the thing it that that's a
rad specimen by the way you know what's
interesting about this guy is that he
knows so much is that his his on is
knowledge of the history of paleontology
and of researching dinosaur bones he
knows so much I call [ __ ] on that
what I'm thinking is that he's reading
from the script that he cobbled together
on [ __ ] Wikipedia I challenge him to
go toe-to-toe with somebody in the
business I don't know like me and go
okay start throwing dates start throwing
specimens I will [ __ ] own you this
video I'm saying I mean he's he's
obviously he knows all these people he
knows about the bone Wars he knows well
who's in charge of all these different
simple google search of largest dinosaur
thing found okay I'm going to write
these three things down on this manila
in on this Manila [ __ ] I understand
I'm not saying that it's it's impressive
and that it's conclusive evidence I'm
saying it's it's impressive that this
guy has done this much research but yet
still has this ridiculous idea and he's
used this yeah
he's using all this data that's actually
factual about how many different people
found how many different things and he's
decided this is proof and all he does
when allegedly in front of it yeah it's
like no sorry over 6,000 specimens were
found their [ __ ] deal with it hunter
Earl Douglas sent 350 tons of excavated
dinosaur bones to the Carnegie Museum of
Natural History throughout his career
all coming from the Dinosaur National
Monument in Utah why do you think it's
called the Dinosaur National Monument
now dr. Louis Chafee and dr. Lowell
it's kiawe actually governed thousands
of dinosaur eggs at a site of only a few
hundred square yard it was called the
tiniest Giants exhibition and has such
finds of huge quantities of fossils in
one area by just a few highly invested
individuals goes against the laws of
natural probability what the most
readin's to the likelihood of forgeries
or concentrate
planting efforts wrong if you find a
fire planting yeah well they plant what
were the things that they planted
oh there's dinosaur bones that they
planted that that's that's not what the
dinosaur bones made out of it like
resins so that is actually an argument
with these jackasses it's like okay so
big paleo the big paleontologist people
like me the Paleo Haley a Big Pharma
yeah like Big Pharma and big VAE and you
know all the podcast Jamie death ergo
we're big podcast for an industry so
they say they not in the black man you
know black helicopter day but they as in
the detractors state the paleontologists
like me will create a fossil whether
it's like a cast or we'll just make one
up and on these expeditions we go out
and we actually bury it and uncover it
and make the news and all that well if
that was true Erik why is it that when
we find something say in I don't know
2008 it's not usually written about
until say 2012 and that's just a symbol
a single note in the Journal of
vertebrate paleontology which I
guarantee you've never read or it's done
as a poster at the Society of vertebrate
paleontology which I will absolutely
guarantee you've never been to and then
the fossils still in prep at that point
we haven't done all the research on it
it's still undiscovered fossil found if
we are going out and investing all of
this money in order to make these fakes
and bury them and pay all of these
people to shut them up and huge
excavations like that we would kind of
want to recoup that money as fast as
possible and immediately dump it to the
news and get paid for spokesmen ships
and all of that but we don't we suffer
Natural History Museum's are some of the
lowest donated to institutions on the
planet art museums are generally number
one there are people that get laid off
all the time for museums museums close
if we were making
all this money in making all this fame
why are there paleontologists out of a
job
why do I know a dozen monitors that
don't have work right now why are there
museums that have problem actually
getting a budget to get an excavation
going that they have to use private
donors that they have to use their board
of directors that they have to go from a
County Museum to a foundation nonprofit
non-profit this is such a line of
[ __ ] [ __ ] that I that that pisses
me off because his simple statements are
looping in thousands and tens of
thousands of employees and museums and
all of that worldwide this would be one
of the largest conspiracies ever other
than I don't know moon hoaxes in a flat
earth flat earth and [ __ ] like the other
one he does yeah that is a good one keep
going Oh dinosaur bones sell for a lot
of money at auctions
it is a profitable business there is
pressure for academics to publish papers
museums are in the business of producing
displays that are popular and appealing
what the nonprofit business via need to
produce material to sell to stay in
business the mainstream media loves to
hype alleged dinosaur finds must be
gained by converting a bland non
dinosaur discovery of a bone of modern
origin into an impressive dinosaur find
and letting artists interpretations and
imaginations take the spotlight okay
Eric the basic boring real find if
that's true then why do dinosaurs become
passé why does somebody like me who has
been on I don't know 13 14 different
television shows talking about
paleontology geology and all that I have
pitched dinosaur like live dig stuff to
BBC and all of that I'm consulting on a
couple projects right now unfortunately
can't name them but dinosaurs become
pass a very very quickly because people
are like oh cool new dinosaur was found
yeah big deal or oh well brontosaurus is
back yeah whatever but the mainstream
media as he said is just like they love
a dinosaur story but that's [ __ ]
that's absolute [ __ ] when
the last like dinosaur document yeah
there was um what was it called autopsy
the t-rex with my friend Tori and that
that okay that was a speculative science
show there's like what happens if we
found a t-rex and cut it open and do an
autopsy that was a hit and then
paleontology TV died again two years ago
I had an a to our National Geographic
documentary about digging up woolly
mammoths in that it aired a night there
was a little bit of press [ __ ] done
the production company that did the the
the thing with Nat Geo is out of
business now just done it's like really
we're pressured and to get this money
then why aren't we making [ __ ] more
why Eric am i a bartender in addition to
a paleontologist in addition to somebody
that's on TV if I'm making all this Big
Pharma are sorry big paleo [ __ ] money
if I'm such a shill okay yeah is that
why I'm a month behind on my car payment
right now is that why I'm trying to
scrape together rent [ __ ] you get
aggressive oh I'm very aggressive hire
these guys prestige fame and attention
there is the bandwagon effect and crowd
behavior and then there are people and
then to wait but wait wait wait wait
live it wait the bandwagon effect and
the crit and crowd behavior like Flat
Earth [ __ ] okay
we're only seven minutes and 53 seconds
into a twenty nine minute video oh [ __ ]
off we don't have to keep going I don't
want you to get too mad I think you kind
of made your point yeah you just pull
the plug any time you want but now it's
like one of those Twitter arguments man
now I'm getting invested control me all
the time because we follow each other we
do um each other and all of a sudden in
my thing it's like I have you on note
because we're both verified it pops up
and it's just like Joe Rogan is tweeting
about flatter [ __ ] and then just go for
it it's like you're I mean like you know
the podcast and like flight commentary
and UFC stuff and like with your with
like trigger coming
and all that that's one thing when you
rile up the cranks man you're just like
you're the same level just actually you
have like how many followers do you have
like 2 million right isn't like on
Twitter TDT take that Darwin like 10
maybe 15,000 I get the same level of
riled from both of you [ __ ] man so we
need to fly him out and have him on the
show this guy this he would be red no
[ __ ] Eric Dubay if he's ever on the show
I want to be outside waiting with a
[ __ ] baseball bat oh no really don't
be violent with him almost almost don't
you want to talk to him what you loved
mean I think you could gain a lot from
sitting down with a guy like this and
just sort of picking him apart because
you would realize what he was wrong
about and instead of him being able to
just spout off on a YouTube video he
would be checked at every step of the
way whenever he said something incorrect
yes but the problem is the only reason
why I would do that he will never change
his mind
well he's probably crazy well duh he's
absolutely crazy but think about it
right now
you have 4 million subscribers that now
know this video exists that no Eric do
base named that know that
paleontologists it can get riled up by
this guy they're now gonna go look if
any one of your listeners is on the
fence about dinosaurs why would you be
but you could have some those are the
people that I would have to try and
convince I will never convince him I
will mock the living [ __ ] out of him
until he wants to put himself into a
chipper shredder but I will never
convince him it's the and that's that's
the thing so all you sicom people out
there we don't do it to try and convince
the big mouthpieces for these movements
we're trying to go for the people that
aren't quite sure if we embarrass the
living [ __ ] out of these people those
people will go wow those guys are idiots
why did I even consider that the world
is flat er the dinosaurs didn't exist or
creationism exists or chemtrails or
Nibiru [ __ ] rogue planets and [ __ ]
like that
[Music]